[Applause]
[Music]
well I just swipe from the University of
Cambridge here's a little taste of what
you can expect from us for the next ten
minutes we're joining a transatlantic
cyber security contest and finding out
how Britain can improve when it comes to
cyber defence then in our games review
we get our hands on the new Nintendo 2ds
XL this week's show is a bit of a cyber
defense special here at the University
of Cambridge some of the most talented
students from the UK and the US have
been competing as international cyber
hunters in a three-day hackathon
showdown and to explain their mission
here's Chris there's a number of steps
and challenges that they have to work
through we're hacking into the software
that controls a drone it's a task set up
to test students at the cyber security
competition and while it's a simulation
it's meant to replicate the sort of
scenario we could expect to see in real
life it could just as easily be a web
front-end to an industrial control
system like a power grid or some sort of
manufacturing plant with bigger more
dangerous equipment running in the
background became breach to Cambridge
competition sees over a hundred cyber
security students taking part in various
hacking challenges teams from the UK and
America compete over three days working
against the clock to defend or attack
mock security networks there are some
missile bunkers in a remote country
which the Special Forces are trying to
get access to and behind enemy lines
some of his mother's to get a copy of a
laptop of a hard disk of someone who
belongs to the enemy we're trying to
build a picture of you know where these
missile sites are and their capabilities
and who's involved without actually
being on the ground obviously it
requires a bit of imagination but the
idea is to add a sense of gravity to the
occasion while also making it fun
there's even leaderboards
and a war room where a referee watches
out for cheating the students certainly
don't look stressed given the fate of
their nation lies at their fingertips
there are aspects that are very
realistic and of course nothing is ever
as realistic as the real thing but the
underlying technical issues
understanding what vulnerabilities and
what kinds of mistakes in the way we
design computer systems
that's a real-world experience that's
made extremely real by doing these kinds
of competitions we've seen a notable
rise in hacking attacks in the last few
months and while this competition might
not be a substitute for the real thing
it provides valuable training for the
cyber warriors of the future Chris Craig
and Sky News in a couple of minutes I'll
be speaking to one of the country's top
cyber security professors and finding
out what he fears the most about our
future it's coming up after a roundup of
some of this week's other tech stories
our roads may be full of electric and
hybrid cars by 2050 it's after plans
were announced by the government to ban
the sale of new diesel and petrol cars
in the UK from 2014
Amazon founder Jeff Bezos topped Bill
Gates as the world's richest person even
if it was only for a matter of hours
shares and Amazon surged on Thursday
putting Bezos whose net worth at sixty
nine point three four billion pounds
according to Forbes although when shares
fell back
so did Basil's another pair of mighty
tech names who made headlines this week
for Tesla's Elon Musk and Facebook
Martin zugerberg mask called Zuckerberg
understanding of artificial intelligence
limited after the Facebook chief had
suggested he was irresponsible for
making public statements about his
concerns over AI and the beginning of a
246 million pound government investment
into battery technology has been
launched which could help bring down
household electricity bills it'll
include creating battery facilities to
store excess wind and solar energy and a
Research Center to help make the country
a leader in electric battery technology
[Music]
stick around for our games review with
searching for survivors in fortnight but
first now one of the reasons this
competition was set up was to help hone
the right skills among cyber defenders
of the future a little bit earlier I had
a chat with professor Frank's to Yano
he's one of the cofounders and I began
by asking him what he thinks Britain is
doing wrong when it comes to cyber
defense
I think Britain is doing many things
right and I'm especially pleased with
the help that the National cybersecurity
Center is offering to businesses that
may not have the expertise in-house but
the one thing that I see as a big
problem is that we just don't have
enough competent people and this is why
I have started with colleagues these
competitions Cambridge - Cambridge I
wish to inspire more than just the
hundred and ten who are in this room
most of the stuff you see in computing
is about using programs that someone
else have written that's not fun that's
pretty boring but there's a lot of
creativity in engaging with computer and
telling computers what to do and
basically writing the rules you get to
protect the society get to protect your
own parents and grandparents from all
these attacks that we see in the media
every day
so I just brought my young daughter this
morning here the competition before you
arrived and I showed her and she's three
months old
show them the competitors say look you
guys in the future are going to be the
people who defend the society the
digital society that she's going to be
living so please do it for her please do
it for your own family the biggest
problem I see so far is that this is
something that is thought of as
something just a specialty for geeks
with hoodies locked up in the room
that's the wrong image and the wrong
message this is something that is
intellectually stimulating it's a very
creative endeavor what is it that you
fear the most about our future the
foundations of this digital society is
not as secure as I would like it to be
and the culture that is today prevalent
in the industry of the people who make
these harder and softer systems does not
put a great value on security that is
what I see as the biggest problem
because it's a structural thing that's
not going to be easy to fix you have to
complete change of mindset we're gonna
break away from digi security now and
bring you some digi entertainment
because Alyssia has our games review for
us this week here she is with her pick
up the latest releases and a new console
everyone's been talking about the
Nintendo switch but there is another
Nintendo console that's hitting shelves
this one's called the Nintendo 2ds XL
lightweight design some pretty big
screens
they've just really honed the designs
everything's a bit smaller more compact
and easier to play which is great for if
you're playing one of the launch titles
say like me topia which is basically
like a fantasy RPG where you cast your
friends and family as the adventurers
who go alongside you it's musical most
of the come
mm that means that you could be going
diving headlong into this adventure but
with the cast of your book club
playing alongside of you taking down a
Dark Lord who's also your sister it's a
bit bonkers but that's what makes it
really really fun they say if it ain't
broke don't fix it and you could say
that for 13 - but what Nintendo's done
is they have given this the toon
franchise a fresh lick of paint the
third-person shooter but rather than
shooting against a like enemies like you
would in uncharted you spray paint if
you're going up in a multiplayer arena
the goal is to cover the walls and the
floor and every surface that you can see
with your paint color and in your
component will try to do the same and
whoever covers the ground in the
quickest amount of time wins if you
really loved the original on your Wii U
and you want to play it again on your
Nintendo switch this is a great jump to
the new console the world of Fortnight
is filled with places to explore and
Link to scavenge there are a lot of
sandbox crafting games out there at the
moment from stardew valley to minecraft
and fortnight is the latest game that's
kind of jumping into this fray
and it's set in a world where 98% of the
population has been ravaged by a
devastating event called the storm so
you work with a group of survivors who
are running through this world and
you're trying to take out these mutant
monster things that have taken over the
world you do that by creating thoughts
you can run through all the desiccated
remains of these buildings and towns and
cities and you can gather up loads of
resources and take them to your thoughts
and build essentially a stronghold that
caters to your particular playstyle
they don't stand a cheat
well that's it from us here in Cambridge
this week join us again next time for
more swiping in the meantime follow us
on Twitter at Sky News flight I'll see
you again next week bye bye
[Applause]
[Music]